(mellow music)
- We're 300 meters off the
coast of Santo Espiritu Island,
and we're lighting an
area to attract plankton.
Mobulas feed on plankton. Hopefully,
they'll come close to us
and we'll be able to swim with them.
(mellow music)
First, plankton come,
then mobulas appear.
These stingrays have been around
for over 20 million years,
but divers like us are recent.
As future visitors are
summoned to the feeding frenzy,
and the sanctuary is threatened.
(mellow music)
What can we do for a
world worth protecting?
National Geographic and Rolex
are sending me across Baja California,
to explore the way wildlife
tourism is evolving
in one of the most biodiverse
regions on the planet.
My first stop is Cabo Pulmo.
I'm here to meet David Castro,
whose family was
instrumental in transforming
a small fishing village
into a global model of sustainability.
- In the '90s, overfishing
had decimated Cabo Pulmo's sea life.
The reef fell sick and the
local economy faltered.
- The Castros and their
neighbors took a chance.
They made a pact to stop fishing
and bet on tourism instead.
Today, David is taking me
on a dive with bull sharks,
to show me how well Cabo
Pulmo's marine population
has recovered since it became
a Nationally Protected Area.
So, we're 500 meters away from the coast,
and there's probably like 10 bull sharks
underneath us right now and
we are the crazy people that are gonna go
under and dive with them.
I'm super excited.
I won't lie, I'm a little scared,
but I think that's normal.
It's the first time I'm
gonna dive with sharks.
(mellow music)
As we dive, we come
across a school of jacks,
swirling like an underwater tornado.
(mellow music)
David, suspended in space,
is wrapped and swallowed.
(mellow music)
From afar, they are a
humbling force of nature,
up close, a wall of drifting eyes.
(mellow music)
This is what a healthy reef looks like.
I almost forget why we're here.
(mellow music)
And then, the sharks come.
Sharks have a negative reputation,
but seeing them up close
changes everything.
(mellow music)
Fear gives way to reverence,
and reverence transforms
into the desire to protect.
- Tourism is kind of the
blood flow that allows —
- Cabo Pulmo managed to build
a blueprint of sustainability
the community is eager
to share with the world.
My next stop is the
Island of Espiritu Santo,
a neighboring wildlife hot spot,
located in the Sea of Cortez.
- A National Sanctuary
and UNESCO Protected Park,
this cluster of small islands
was almost developed into a casino resort,
until locals petitioned the
government for protection.
Since it was declared a
Nationally Protected Area
in 1995, small tour
boats having been taking
adventurous travelers to
explore what many consider to be
the world's richest outdoor aquarium.
- While most tourists
snorkel with sea lions,
we decide to dive.
We swim towards the
massive rock formations
jutting from the ocean floor.
Between the towers of red
rock, sea lions play in a cave.
They are fast and agile,
and although they gently bite
our hands and scuba suits,
it's not easy to keep their attention.
A new tour group arrives,
then another, and another.
Suddenly dozens of tourists
invade the surface above us,
blocking the sunlight,
and the sea lions scatter.
Guides call this the red wave.
Red, the color of their life vests.
I wonder if activities like these
are blurring the line
between natural sanctuary
and amusement park.
I'm on my way to La Paz Bay to explore
Baja's most established
wildlife adventure.
The way tourism has evolved here
may serve as an example
for newer activities.
I'm meeting Dení Ramirez,
La Paz's foremost whale shark
expert and conservationist.
Her work has been instrumental in ensuring
tourism isn't harming the whale shark.
- Dení takes volunteers
on her research missions.
By including visitors, she hopes to forge
a stronger balance between
tourism and conservation.
Whale sharks are migratory and
collect by the hundreds here
when the waters are warm
and rich with nutrients.
They filter thousands of gallons of water
through their gills to capture the
massive blooms of plankton they
need to sustain their diet.
The camera she places
on its fin will yield
intimate footage from the
whale shark's point of view.
(mellow music)
The goal is to see how
the shark's behavior
changes in the presence
of people and boats.
(mellow music)
- In traveling through Baja,
I've seen the impact of wildlife tourism.
It can transform a local economy
and help sustain a natural habitat.
To find that balance, we must blur the line
between local, visitor,
and conservationist.